l'a constaté. Mélissa François.
- Ce n'est pas un jour d'école,e
sont en classe au Cégep
de Rosemont et ils sont
très concentrés.
Ils y sont pour faire leurs
devoirs de français et de
mathématique et aussi pour
passer du temps avec leur
mentor. C'est le cas
de Carolina, 10 ans.
- C'est le fun, c'est amusant.
On fait beaucoup de choses
aussi.
- L'initiative s'appelle l'École
des Grands, c'est un programme
parascolaire de mentorat, où des
étudiants du collégial offrent
de l'aide aux devoirs aux
enfants issus de milieux
défavorisés.
ALISHA WISSANJI, directrice
générale, Fondation W
- On identifie les écoles
les plus défavorisées au Québec.
De là, il y a des élèves avec
des moyennes entre 50 à 70 %,
des élèves vulnérables au
primaire, qui viennent au cégep
du quartier recevoir de l'aide
aux devoirs en français et en
maths, comme ici, dans le fond.
Les mentors sont des collégiens
bénévoles du cégep, issus
de tous les programmes et de
tous les profils scolaires.
- Pour les mentors du groupe,
l'appui apporté à ces enfants
dépasse largement le contexte
académique. Nito Bullon en sait
quelque chose.
NITO BULLON
étudiant au cégep et mentor
- J'ai toujours eu la répu
d'être parmi les pires de la
classe, qui avait les pires
notes. Il a suffit seulement
d'une seule personne, un seul
professeur qui m'a dit
que j'étais une
intelligente qui pouvait
avoir... qui avait de la valeur.
- L'initiative semble avoir
des résultats concrets.
Une amélioration des résultats
scolététététété observée.
- Les élèves qui ont participé
à l'École des Grands augmentent
leur note en français, en
mathématiques et en sciences.
- Selon cette professeureivivivs
conditions doivent être réunies
pour que ce type de programme
favorise réellement la réussite
scolaire.
CATHERINE TURCOTTE Dép.éducation
et formation spécialisées, UQAM
- Créer un climat de confiance,
être bienveillant, tout ça, mais
aussi être capable de recentrer
sur la tâche, parce qu'être
capable d'avoir un but préci
de séance de tutorat en séance
de tutorat, ça aussi,
c'est important.- - - - - - Le e
dessert actuellement cinq écoles
primaire de Montréal
et de Trois-Rivières.
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Montréa